[Music]
48 hours is investigating the mysterious
death of an american woman in africa
bianca rudolph suffered a deadly gunshot
wound while she was visiting zambia with
her husband lawrence the case center is
on the crucial question did bianca
accidentally shoot herself that's what
zambian police say but as 48 hours
contributor deborah patter reports
american investigators believe lawrence
rudolph murdered his wife
in 2016 lawrence rudolph and his wife
bianca were preparing to return home
from a hunting trip in zambia
lawrence says he was in the cabin's
bathroom when he heard a gunshot and his
wife scream finding her dead shot in the
chest he would tell authorities bianca
must have shot herself while packing up
their gun in its case gun safety rules
and regulations stipulate once the
hunting trip was ended the weapon should
have been rendered safe james galliano a
retired fbi special agent and cbs news
consultant has questions over why the
gun would have even been loaded to think
that they would have left the weapon off
safe
loaded
and then a finger could have gotten in
the trigger it just does not make sense
it is especially puzzling says galliano
because of the rudolph's background
lawrence rudolph and his wife bianca
were avid hunters these were not rookies
and they understand gun safety rules and
precautions
lawrence rudolph for his port has
maintained innocence throughout this
investigation you can watch deborah's
full report tonight at 8 eastern 7
central on the cbs news streaming
network